Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is not some hot new Two Minute Papers
merchandise - this is what a new cloth simulation
paper is capable of doing today.
So good!
And today, we are also going to see how to
put back the holes into holey geometry, and
do it quickly!
But wait a second, that is impossible.
We know that yarn-based cloth simulations
take forever to compute.
Here is an example, we showcased this previous
work approximately 60 episodes ago.
And curiously, get this, some of the simulations
here were nearly 60 times faster than the
yarn-based reference simulation.
That is amazing.
However, we noted that even though this technique
was a great leap forward, but of course, it
wasn’t perfect, there was a price to be
paid for this amazing speed, which was, look,
that pulling effects on individual yarns were
neglected.
That amazing holey geometry is lost.
I noted that I’d love to get that back.
You will see in a moment that maybe, my wish
comes true today.
Hmm!
So, quick rundown.
We either go for a mesh-based cloth simulation.
These are really fast, but, no holey geometry.
Or, we choose the yarn-level simulations,
these are the real deal, however, they take
forever.
Unfortunately, still, there seems to be no
way out here.
Now, let’s have a look at this new technique.
It promises to try to marry these two concepts,
or in other words, use a fast mesh simulator,
and add the yarn-level cloth details on top
of it.
Now of course, that is easier said than done,
so let’s see how this new method can deal
with this challenging problem.
So, this is the fast mesh simulation to start
with, and now, hold on to your papers, and
let’s add those yarns.
Oh my, that is beautiful.
I absolutely love how at different points,
you can even see through these garments.
Beautiful.
So, how does it do all this magic?
Well, look at this naive method.
This neglects the proper tension between the
yarns, and, look at how beautifully they tighten
as we add the new method on top of it.
This technique can do it properly.
And not only that, but it also simulates how
the garment interacts with a virtual body
in a simulated world.
Once again, note how the previous, naive method
neglects the tightening of the yarns.
So, I am super excited, let’s see how long
we have to wait for this.
Are we talking fast mesh simulation timings,
or slow yarn simulation timings?
My goodness.
Look at that!
The mesh part runs on your processor, while
the yarn part of the simulation is implemented
on the graphics card.
And, whoa, the whole thing runs in the order
of milliseconds, easily in real time.
Even if we have a super detailed garment with
tens of millions of vertices in the simulation,
the timings are in the order of tens of milliseconds
at worst.
That’s also super fast.
Wow.
So, yes, part of this runs on our graphics
card and in real time.
Here, we have nearly a million vertices, not
a problem.
Here, nearly two million vertices, two million
points if you will, it runs like a dream.
And it only starts to slow down when we go
all the way to a super detailed piece of garment
with 42 million vertices.
And here, there is so much detail that finally,
not the simulation technique is the bottleneck,
but the light simulation algorithm is.
Look, there are so many high-frequency details
that we would need a higher-resolution video,
or more advanced antialiasing techniques to
resolve all this detail.
All this means that the simulation technique
did its job really well.
So, finally, yarn-level simulations in real
time.
What a time to be alive!
Huge congratulations to the entire team, and
the first author, Georg Sperl, who is still
a PhD student, making important contributions
like this.
And, get this - Georg’s short presentation
was seen by… oh my…61 people.
Views are not everything.
Not even close!
But, once again, if we don’t talk about
this work here, I am worried that almost no
one will.
And this is why Two Minute Papers exists.
Subscribe if you wish to see more of these
miracle papers, we have some great ones coming
up.
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!